INSIDE CLIMATE PLEDGE ARENA.
AND SCORES ON A
PHIL KESSEL KNOWS HOW TO SCORE.
HE HAS TIME T THE BACK
IN ON OFFENSIVELY.
GOOD SHOT RIGHT ON NET, HITS HIM
HIGH UP I I
FROM THE "MIRACLE ONGRUBAUER FO
PHILIPP GRUBAUER.
CLAYTON KELLER THOUGHT HE HAD
SHOULDER ON LYUBUSHKIN, THEY JAM
>> JT: ANOTHER LOOK AT NOW McCA
THE LINE, JOHANSSON OFF A  SHOT.
JORDAN EBERLE USES BACK OF THE
NET, ABLE POINT, MAYO HAS A TOU
TIME EXTENSION, GETS THE BLOCKER
OVER.
EBERLE CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
NE IT AWAY
TO GOURDE.
LOOK OUT, SCHMALTZ, A SHOT,DO,
HAS LARSSON BACKTRACKING HAVING!
SHORTHANDED GOAL!
THE FIRST SHOHOND
IN.
DOES A GOOD JOB, CHANGING THE
FRONT BY FLEURY AND POKED HOME
BY THE MOVE FROM AGAIN.
WENNBERG, DANGLE, OUT IN FRONT,
CLEANED UP B TO GO
HERE'S EBERLE. GOOD
OPPO LOOKS AROUND.
THAT'S HOCKEY, POST,
GALCHENYUK SCORES.TTEMPT.
BUT EMPTY NET, TOO MANY
OPPORTUNITY TOSSES GET IT TO
WITH YAWNING CAGE.